there's some [__] cool music out
there huh I hate music though
it's just too much
oh my God
Dragnet
I know the City of Angels on this
particular location we happen to witness
a pagan ritual in progress well is it
really [__] on my algorithm huh
we're just in time we have stumbled into
a major Dan Aykroyd
and Tom Hanks are doing it
they wrap it
oh wow
Tom Hanks is seven in this
bro Dan Aykroyd was funny as [__]
[Music]
wow Timex did Philadelphia you know
dude you know what's crazy is
honestly uh
wow what the [__] bro this is so weird
while I'm sending this to the group chat
you're a dangerous mob and yo rapping is
so easy you know
I love how people try to pretend like
it's not easy and [__]
and like how like it's really hard to be
a good rapper like dude you could just
[__] this is the same [__] thing
as all those other bullshits in the 90s
I mean granted I know that that wasn't
dude everyone's gonna look back at hip
hop and be like that was bad
I love uh hip-hop though so
exactly Beastie Boys that's the one
where people are like Beastie Boys was
the [__] and it's like this is basically
what they did
Beastie Boys came at the right time
just like Bone Thugs and Harmony people
are like yeah yeah it's so good ah that
[__] sucks man I'll stir fry you with my
walk Ah that's [__] sucks huh
dude Bone Thugs-N-Harmony yeah it
sounded nice but it's
easy
now hey that [__] sucks huh
it's just so bad
and then people will be like nah they'll
die by that [__] yo it was so not
necessarily uh uh Bone Thugs but BC boys
people will just stand on that [__]
I love The Intergalactic Planetary song
though because my cat because Calvin
loves it
um
wow
that was just crazy that was just
gorgeous what a gorgeous I'm gonna watch
I got a lot
killing it here
I can't believe my wife let my baby [__]
in the pool
I'm gonna uh
I'm probably gonna
call a pool guy after this
[Music]